à mirabel ce que vivent des filion est
contraire au bon sens d'un propriétaire
durable à sucre la dernière chose qu'on
peut penser que couper eric fillion est
devenu co propriétaire de l'érablière
familiale en 2016 c'était bien parti
déjà l'obtention de la certification
biologique et une médaille d'or
puis une petite chenille indigènes a
frappé de manière brutale
la livrée des forêts
des 76 hectares d'érable en production
ont été attaqués mais une licence
durablement ont dû être abattus dans
l'érable à sucre à ma connaissance c'est
une des premières fois on voit de
mortalité aussi importante
l'insecte une chenille défoliant tu es
le plus important ravageur de feuillus
au pays une défoliation de quelques
années a faibli en érable
mais ce n'est pas censé le faire mourir
eric fillion ne s'est pas méfié de la
libre et on la voyait apparaître en
première année on s'est dit on des
filiations certain pourcentage on
devrait peut-être 1 25% de défoliation
choléra mais il ignorait que ses érables
attaqué était déjà affaibli par un
drainage imparfait du sol problèmes dont
les impacts sont aujourd'hui accentuée
par un nouvel élément
les changements climatiques ont neuf
sublime on le sait depuis quelques
années des coups d'eau donc des
précipitations très importantes ce qu'on
voyait pas aux trois fois les épisodes
de pluies abondantes ont porté le coup
fatal
lorsqu'un deuxième stress qui est
embarqué sur ces mêmes arbres loeb est
en train de la mortalité rapide de selon
le ministère québécois des forêts en
2017 306 milles hectares de forêts ont
été défauts liés à divers degrés en 2018
la superficie totale atteignait 390
mille hectares les zones les plus
touchées sont dans les laurentides
l'outaouais et l'estrie le seul moyen de
le dont disposent les acériculteurs et
l'arrosage au btk insecticides naturels
utilisés contre la tordeuse des
bourgeons de l'épinette ici rachel
brillant radio canada québec